you know i was like something in me had
this like obsessive
maniacal drive to like no i really like
can be this
i just believed it and i wouldn't let
anything [ __ ] stop me i just
really [ __ ] wanted it and and at the
time i probably
looked and sounded crazy because the
music was horrible
like horrible like trash and just
learning how to like
find my voice learning song structure
how to count bars how to
you know how to really produce music and
um
but like i always tell people man if
it's a labor of love it's like
if you love something inside and out
you're gonna do it a lot because you
love it and if you do it a lot you
eventually get better at it and then you
get better at it you you
improve it recognize it every day yeah
what's your call about all this what do
you want to leave what do you feel like
you want to leave
uh i want to transcend and and and and
yeah and be
you know iconic and timely and be like
michael jackson i want to be like
michael tyson
yeah so you know now but like
you know i i i'm inspired by the use of
the world
like people that transcend their spaces
a lot of your music is based on like
you're pretty much you're
he's you know he writes about his
experiences yeah
i think hip-hop naturally is just
autobiographical you know
in its nature it's like you're telling
stories of
you know from your perspective and all
that um but
you know i again like like getting back
to this i think um
you know i am inspired by you know
people are different walks of life
different
spaces different you know whether it's
yeah
there's a commonality you know among
people who want to be great
people who take things seriously and
people who really have that drive and
that push
and i see that you know i mean like the
way
you know you've had these different
phases of your life and career
and i mean the the space you're in right
now
maybe even the best you know something
you know that's crazy
i always noticed this well i don't know
if i noticed this but um
i always lived by this theory um
i've met a lot of great men mm-hmm but
not many of the great men i met were
good men
yeah so i tried hard in my life to try
to be a good man i'm not saying i
am but that's my goal in life to try to
be a good man
you strike me as a good man well i try
to be honest i haven't just met you but
honestly
trying to try to hardly still happen i
think characteristics about myself
yeah and there's and there's things that
i've i feel the same way and it's
it's a challenge especially right and
and but
you know in any level of like limelight
spotlight entertainment
you know you have a lot of things thrown
at you and you have to you know you
carry a lot of weight and
and you know you provide for a lot of
people and you know you have a lot of
things being
done that's something though what do you
think we provide for a lot of people
we don't feel as if we were worth
anything we can't find somebody to
provide for them
yeah we have to be able to take care of
subconsciously our mind we have to take
care of somebody
yeah he doesn't that's a weight but
that's
you know that's that's what you're
conditioned and built for
yeah exactly you know what i'm saying
and i mean you're
you know you're built different yeah
there's a there's a higher calling
and and you know of course it can get
challenging and exhausting at times bro
because it's like
you got a different responsibility than
some